وواقع اليم لمزيد من المتابعه معنا الان
من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت ولكن قبل
ذلك نتوقف مع هذا العاجل مراسل الجزيره
يقول وصول جثامين ثلاثه شهداء وعدد من
الجرحى الى مستشفى ناصر اثر قصف اسرائيلي
مستمر على خان يونس جنوب القطاع من جديد
نرحب بهشام زقوت لنرصد معه ايضا التطورات
الميدانيه والانسانيه في ظل هذا الواقع
الصعب و
تكدس النازحين وهذا العدد المهول منهم
المتواجدين في
رفح بالفعل الازدهار عدد مهول متواجد في
رفح من النازحين الفلسطينيين يواجهون
اوضاعا كارثيه هذه الاوضاع على عده صعد
الصعيد الانساني والصعيد الصحي وصعيد
الخدمات والبنيه التحتيه الناس هنا في رفح
يتكدسون في الطرقات في الشوارع على
الارصفه وفي الاراضي الزراعيه ونصبوا
خياما ويواجهون تحديات جمه هذه التحديات
متمثله في بكل تاكيد في نقص الغذاء في نقص
الدواء في نقص المياه الصالحه للشرب وفي
نقص البنى التحتيه الخاصه بهم وفي ظل هذه
الاوضاع بكل تاكيد يواجهون ايضا الاحوال
الجويه السيئه حيث يضرب ما بين فينه واخرى
ويوم واخر قطاع غزه منخفضات جويه تؤثر
بشكل كبير على هؤلاء النازحين الذين نصبوا
الخيام والتي لا تقيهم لا من برد الشتاء
ولا من القصف الاسرائيلي المستمر
والمتواصل حتى على رفح رغم انها منطقه
مكدسه بالنازحين الفلسطينيين وباعداد
السكان الكبيره مليون و300 ال نسمه
يتواجدون في رفح وهم يواجهون صعوبات جمه
ولكن الاصعب من كل ذلك هم المرضى الذين
يواجهون تحديات كبيره وكارثه خاصه المرضى
اصحاب الامراض المزمنه الذين لا يتوفر
لديهم دواء مرض الضغط غير متوفر اقلام
الانسولين الخاصه بمرضى السكري غير متوفره
وكذلك مرضى الكلى الذين يحتاجون الى غسيل
للكلى في المستشفيات وهم يحتاجون الى ذلك
كل يومين على الاقل الان يواجهون تحدي
كبير ويواجهون خطر الموت لان هؤلاء لا
يتوفر لديهم الاجهزه في رفح المستشفيات هي
مستشفيات بسيطه وبالتالي لا يتوفر هذا
العدد الكافي لكل هؤلاء الاعداد من
النازحين ولكل هؤلاء الاعداد من مرضى
الكلى كذلك مرضى السرطان لا يتوفر لديهم
الادويه منذ بدا الحصار الاسرائيلي على
قطاع غزه منذ 16 عاما وبالتالي هم يحتاجون
الى العلاج في الخارج وكانوا قبل ذلك قبل
بدء الحرب يتوجهون الى مستشفيات الضفه
الغربيه او حتى الى مستشفيات مصر اعداد
قليله منهم من تمكنت من السفر واعداد
والاعداد الباقيه متواجده هنا لا يتوفر
لها لا دواء ولا حتى مسكنات المسكنات غير
متوفره وبالتالي هم يواجهون الان ايضا خطر
الموت بالاضافه الى امراض كثيره مزمنه
وامراض كثيره ايضا معديه باتت تنتشر في
قطاع غزه في ظل هذه داد الكبيره من السكان
لكن كل هذه الامراض وكل هذه التحديات
يواجهونها تحت قصف اسرائيلي مستمر وتحت
استمرار وفي ظل استمرار القتل من خلال قصف
الا قصف الجيش الاسرائيلي لهذه المنازل
المدنيه في مناطق مختلفه وخاصه في رفح
وايضا في دير البلح شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من
رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت و